Marcel Jansen im Fragenlotto bei klickum
das bedeutet natürlich wir legen wieder
die Daumenschrauben an und er ist da
auch ganz bereit willig dabei und zieht
eigentlich fast nur rote Fragen und da
geht's dann z.B um seine vielen
Verletzungen und was zur Sprache kommt
sehr interessant ob es bald einen
kleinen Marcel Jansen gibt weil auch bei
ihm war es ja so Vater Trainer er wurde
Fußballspieler also ist da vielleicht
was zu erwarten seid gespannt und wenn
ihr es gut findet aboknopf da oben nicht
vergessen zu drücken da gibt's mehr
Marcel Jansen und mehr klicksum ja
Marcel bisher war ja alles angenehm kom
der schwierige Teil ja jetzt kommt der
schwierig Teil pass auf das sind wenen
Fragen Lotto das sind gemeine und
harmlose Fragen die roten sind gemeine
Fragen speziell für dich auf dich
zugeschnitten du kannst so viel ziehen
wie du möchtest greif rein blind sehend
ein Auges also wie du möchtest also rot
sind die gemein ne rot sind die gemein
die finde ich ja immer besonders
interessant ja genau wie geht das jetzt
hier ja du kannst das oben pass auf ich
kann einfach genau einfach abdrehen und
fertig ist die lau oder daneben legen
keine Mühen gescheut ey alter Schwede
alles Hand gefertig
ja jetzt kannst du mich übrigens wieder
angucken also magst du das Krankenbett
mehr als den
Fußballplatz ich denke wenn man das
Krankenbett kennt weiß man dass es nie
was angenehmes ist aber ich denke auch
und und das mal ist ja auch man kann ja
auch mit Sachen aufräumen also wenn ich
so oft krank war dann weiß ich nicht wie
ich 150 Bundesligaspiel 40 Länderspiel
und drei Turniere spielen konnte deshalb
sage ich immer was wäre wenn ich mal
komplett gesund gewesen wä also ich sehe
das ich sehe das ich sehe das nicht so
eng mit dem Krankenbett wobei auch
Krankenbett glaube ich beim Fußballer ja
nichts angenehmes ist sondern du musst
wahrscheinlich immer arbeiten ne das
Problem ist man muss Nacharbeiten dann
und das ist wie wenn man kommt auff an
auf die Verletzung aber ein halbes Jahr
oder zi D Monate nicht in der Schule war
aber man möchte unbedingt sein Abschluss
erreichen und auch eben die
dazugehörigen Noten die man braucht um
um sich zu bewerben und so so ist im
Fußball auch weil die anderen schlafen
nicht die trainieren auch und ich denke
wenn man aufgrund von Unfällen oft im
Krankenbett war aber am Ende immer noch
da oben steht und man einen bei einer WM
sieht oder am Wochenende in der
Bundesliga dann ist es ein steh auf
Menchen und da kann man auch stolz draf
sein und wenn es passiert ist es halt so
ich habe natürlich wieder eine rote
genommen find ich am
besten du hast Bayern München nach nur
einem Jahr verlassen hast du den
Leistungsdruck nicht ausgehalten
anderthalb Jahre war genau ja die die
zwei Saison mit rein ich war ja es
richtig war ja im Jahr m Hitzfeld
bei Bayern und ich konnte den Druck
nicht aushalten dass dass wir im Jahr
nur drei Spiele verloren haben und
deutscher Meister geworden sind und
dbpkal Spiel dfbpkal hab ich muss hier
unbedingt weg ich will keine Titel mehr
gewinnen und deshalb bin ich weggelaufen
habe auch zu viel gespielt dafür dass
ich noch verletzt war beim otma und war
eine geile Zeit und ich bin weggegangen
weil ich nach einer anderen Aufgabe
gesucht habe weil die Situation sich so
nicht gestellt hat
und bin damit g so oft eingesetzt das
war der Hintergrund da gab's dann halt
das war halt nicht so und Hamburg wollte
unbedingt ich habe gesagt okay ich bin h
nach Bayern gekommen als junger Mensch
bin von Gladbach gekommen bin direkt in
die statelf gekommen hatte ein superjah
natürlich mit mit verletzungssorg und
hätte sich schon noch draufpacken können
und es war okay es war jetzt auch nicht
so dass danach die glorreiche Zeit
eingeleitet wurde auf der Position bei
Bayern also von daher war das jetzt
nicht so schlimm aber ist das nicht
trotzdem ganz bes
Verein ich hatte nur ich hatte nur
besondere Vereine brü Münch gab bin ich
geboren groß geworden da sind meine
Eltern Familie Cousin Fan ich selber
auch Fan Bayern München ist ist für mich
ein Verein wo man aufschauen kann
natürlich hat man gerne immer gegen die
die Erfolg haben auch so ein bisschen
mehr Aggression gehört auch dazu
sportlich gesehen auch geil gegen be müs
unbedingt gewinnen sehe ich ja selber
auch so wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr bei
denen Spiele aber andererseits muss man
einfach auch mal Sachen anerkennen und
wenn Verein sich über Jahrzehnte was auf
arbeitet ja dann haben Sie sich verdient
ich kann ihn ja nicht sag sagen ihr hab
scheiß ihr hab gute Arbeit geleistet
warum kauft ihr euch so teure Spieler
ist ja quatsch es wä wie eine wie eine
Firma die gut wirtschaftet und deshalb
andere Mittel zur Verfügung hat aber sie
haben ja auch irgendwo angefangen klein
und deshalb kann ich das Anerkennen aber
sportlich gesehen da ist es natürlich
immer interessant die
wegzuputzen wobei sie machen es ja immer
wieder doch spannend
ja nicht so langweilig was wä was wäre
der Fußball wenn man sich nicht so dran
reiben könnte über die Vereine über
Traditionen über Derbys das gehört doch
dazu zu solange es im Rahmen bleibt und
nicht so abdriftet ist das alles okay
jetzt bin ich gespannt was gibt's denn
genau die die noch eine
rote schrabst du dich schrebst du nicht
manchmal zu dicht am vorzeitigen
Karriereende vorbei es ist jetzt gar
nicht insgesamt keine keine negativ
Frage ich weiß wie sie gemeint ist aber
ich glaube dass kein Fußballer selbst
wenn er noch nicht mal eine Grippe hatte
sagen kann dass das nicht von heute auf
morgen passieren kann und ein dummer
Zweikampf eine falsche grche einmal
falsch aufkommen einmal eine böse
Knieverletzung etc dann kann es vorbei
sein das zeht für jeden so und ich bin
froh dass meine Verletzung zwar nicht
immer leicht waren aber dass ich nach
jeder mich zurückgekämpft habe und auch
wenn es kompliziert war aber ich muss
sagen ist auch alles gut verhalt so dass
ich mittlerweile wieder voll im Saft
stehe
und deshalb kann das eigentlich kein
Spieler wirklich sagen weil Sportler da
zählen nicht nur die Fußballer zu gesund
sowieso das wichtigste aber für
Leistungssportler halt auch die
Gesundheit die man dazu braucht um
diesen Beruf oder diese Leidenschaft
ausfüllen zu können und deshalb glaube
ich ist kein Spieler davor vor geschützt
knapp von irgendetwas vorbei zu sein das
kann Schell ist wirklich auch immer
dieses Gefühl man schrabt da selbst
selbst wenn man keine Verletzung hat
sieht man dass es dann ganz schnell
gehen kann dass man kein Verein mehr
kriegt oder sonst irgendwas also das da
ist niemand vor geschützt ne und da
braucht man dann halt eben wieder Mut
und etc die Dinge die wir eben hatten um
an sich zu glauben und sagen okay
passiert und das bringt einen im Leben
weiter gut komm grüne wir haben noch du
knst eine rote ziehen od no grüne was
über mich ich ne die rote genau okay ja
die sind immer die machen doch am
meisten Spaß irgendwie ne ja mich
interessiert das ja wenn man das ist ja
so bisschen mehr das gehässische und
damit möchte man möchte ich mich auch
nicht ich lauf da nicht vor weg da Ken
nichts zu
verstecken ist dein gut Menschentum
nicht nur eine
Pflichtübung also wenn das wenn das
meine Lebensaufgabe wäre irgendwie
ganzen Tag löchnd rumzulaufen und hinten
rum als reheinländer ist es einfach so
und äh ich habe immer gesagt heute Tage
besteht bei vielen mehr die Aufgabe drin
in allem immer das Schlechte zu sehen
und nur zu jammern aber ich glaube dass
wir hier im Westen egal ob man
Fußballprofi ist oder einen ganz
normalen Job hat keinen Grund haben
irgendwie zu jammern andere kämpfen um
ihr Überleben gerade in der Welt oder
oder müssen sich müssen sich ihr Brot
ganz harte Arbeiten oder Ihr Dach überm
Kopf irgendwie suchen und wir sind ja
immer nur am Jammer immer alles so
anstrengend ist und ja der hat ja gut
reden weil der ist ja Profi ich war
früher auch nicht auch nicht Profi und
meine Eltern mussten auch über 30 Jahre
lang hart arbeiten und haben nichts
geschenkt bekommen hat auch keiner
gefragt ja komm wir geben dir mal oder
hier her Jansen oder Frau Jansen da
haben wir mal was
deshalb ich bin wirklich so und wenn man
mir nicht glaubt ich kann ja auch kein
dazu zwingen ne ich meine mich wird es
auch nerven wenn da einer ist der gut
drauf ist
und immer versucht sich zu entwickeln
immer dann das nervt wenn man selber mit
sich nicht im rein ist Nerven so Leute
und deshalb bin ich ja sogar froh wenn
ich damit Leute manchmal Ärger und sag
man der geht mir um Sack dieser Jansen
finde ich gut weil vielleicht kommt
irgendwann der umkche und sagen mal
warum kann ich das nicht haben weil es
jeder haben kann ich bin nicht als
Fußballer auf die Welt gekommen mit
meinem Dicken Auto oder sonst irgende
scheiß was sowieso erstmal nicht
glücklich macht sondern auch ganz
einfach unnormal arbeiterfilie zur
Schule gegangen musste mal gucken wie
mein Weg ist Pubertät alles ganz normal
und das kam dann halt und das ist ein
Teil meines Lebens aber der ist auch
irgendwann wieder vorbei und dann geht
das normale Leben weiter auch das
Engagement für die gute Sache damit
meine das das
ja aber könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen
dass das zu viel ist ist ja relativ
authentisch also ich könnte ja jetzt
auch jeden Monat zweimal auf
irgendwelchen roten
teppichveranstaltungen rumlaufen die für
irgendwie einen guten Zweck sind das
machst du nicht das mache ich ja gar
nicht also ich
weiß wenn es passt mache ich es auch
aber ist jetzt meistens so dass das muss
irgendwie wo ich sage habe ich Bock
drauf und wenn ich das so ein bisschen
über mein mein meine Leute und meine
Ideen so ein bisschen steuern kann da
was zu machen mache ich es gerne wobei
das nicht heißt dass alles schlecht sein
muss nur hat sich nicht so ergeben und
versucht das z bisschen selber zu
steuern und Spaß zu machen unterstützt
aber natürlich dann auch auch Kumpels
oder oder andere Prominente wenn die mal
was machen wollen und da wirklich was
hinter steckt da bin ich natürlich dabei
aber deshalb ich find es jetzt auch
nicht zu viel weil kann man nie zu viel
machen eigentlich wenn man Leute
motiviert irgendwie ein bisschen was
Gutes zu tun gut komm eine grüne aber
zum Schluss weil sonst
äh scheiden wir ja so äh unzufrieden
vielleicht auseinander nie gut okay kann
über alles
reden
welche Tugenden machen dich zum Guten
Fußballspieler Tugenden ja man könnte
jetzt so Alibi sagen ne Rennen kämpfen
ich glaube einfach wenn man wenn man
weiß auch wenn es nicht immer einfach
ist warann man mal und warum man mal mit
fußball angefangen hat nämlich als Kind
weil man diese Kugel so toll fand und
wollte halt die ganze Zeit gegen treten
und wollte oder wollte damit besondere
Sachen machen und auch wenn es nicht
immer einfach ist auch für mich nicht
und nicht immer einfach war ist ist
einfach die die Tugend sollte sein eben
wieder zu diesem Spaß diesem kreativen
zurückzufinden wo der Ursprung drin lag
und
nicht nicht diesen Draht verlieren und
dann irgendwann das Fußball so zu sehen
ja dann bin ich ein Star dann habe ich
das dann das ist das Quatsch also das
haben andere Sportarten auch
Basketballer verdienen verstehe die
scheiß Millionäre im Fußball das
verstehe ich nie so ganz weil ein
Basketballer alleine wenn er ein
bisschen was kann verdient so viel wie
eine ganze wie ganze HSV Verein und
deshalb ist in Deutschland immer so ein
bisschen da regen die sie auch verstehe
ich gar nicht aber wo auch die frageum
geht zu einer guten t ich GU diese
Ehrlichkeit bal Z be nur diesen Faden
warum man das eigentlich mal gemacht hat
und da immer hinzuhören und dann sehen
die Leute auch dass du auf dem Platz
ehrliche Arbeit ablieferst weil die sich
irgendwie wiedererkennen zu dem weil
jeder kann Fußball spielen er muss nicht
jeder gut sein aber ich finde das ja
auch geil meine Jungs kicken ja auch in
der Kreisliga A und sonst irgendwo und
ich guck mir die Spiel auch an sag nicht
was S das denn für Blinde nee weil es
geht um Spiel es geht nicht rum wer kann
was besser es geht heutzutage in der
Welt so macht und wer hat das größte
rauto größte Haus was gut das ist für
mich Zeitverschwendung ich versuche
einfach die die Charaktertypen und und
Charaktereigenschaften jeder jeder Sache
so mitzunehmen okay das heißt was ich
heute gelernt habe ist man muss als
guter Fußballspieler genauso wie als
guter Youtuber authentisch sein ja also
finde ich ganz wichtig authentisch ist
zwar auch nur ein Wort an sich aber wenn
man verstand veren man muss es verstehen
und authentisch zu sein heißt einfach
irgendwo dann bleibt man so irgendwo bei
der wirklichen Wahrheit man kann viel vi
reden man kann vieles gut zu gut reden
vieles schlecht reden
und muss man eigentlich gar nicht man
muss man muss versuchen authentisch zu
bleiben und auch wissen was will ich
wirklich ich habe dieses eine Leben und
was mache ich damit
und mir ist zu viel noch um abschließend
zu sagen zu viel ich brauche das das und
das um glücklich zu werden Schwachsinn
hatte ich vorher auch nicht wenn man um
materielle Dinge springt braucht man
nicht stimmt nicht du brauchst was das
ist dass du eben wie gesagt aber es
haben wir fast alle dir was zu essen
kaufen kannst paar vernünftige kl dass
du raus in die Welt kannst und dann hat
jeder seine Möglichkeiten es ist
natürlich nicht immer einfach und es
gibt schicksalsfläge für die ist keiner
geschützt um Gottes Willen
aber für die anderen gibt's immer eine
Chance egal auf welchem Weg und das das
finde ich muss man sehen dass das Glas
jetzt nicht immer nur halble leer ist
das nervt einfach nervt wann war der
Moment wo du dazu diesem wann diese
Erkenntnis gereift ist diese Erkenntnis
kommt ja auch wenn man selber down ist
wenn man selber nach Verletzungen oder
Freundschaften Beziehungen kaputt gehen
etc Enttäuschungen von anderen Menschen
aus so Situation sieht man das
eigentlich und dann denke ich mir
irgendwann ja eben zum Glück da habe ich
so ein bisschen be unsus dem reheinland
das vorgelebt ja leck TCH weiter und ne
ist wieder neuer Tag morgen und dann
packen wir es an weil letztenendes du
hast nur die zwei Möglichkeiten etwas
gut oder schlecht zu sehen und
Gesundheit braucht man alle das ist auch
ein bisschen Schicksal da kann man nie
verschützen aber alles andere kann man
ein bisschen mit Steuern und das
versuche ich immer jedem mitzugeben und
deshalb ist es auch nicht so dass ich
einfach immer nur so tue als ob ich dann
zu irgendjemand nett bin ich habe ein
riesig Respekt vor jedem her Ordner ist
bcker ist es spielt keine Rolle meine
Eltern haben selber in normalen Berufen
gearbeitet und das ist auch völlig in
Ordnung okay in diesem daseß ich bei mir
die logische Frage an von wegen
weitergeben wann kriegst du
Nachwuchs bin Familienmensch und das ist
auch ganz für mich ganz ganz wichtig und
mag auch sehr gerne Kinder und es wird
sicherlich keine 10 Jahre mehr dauern
aber natürlich ist auch immer viel los
und ich möchte es zumindestens ein
bisschen genießen können und nicht
gerade in der wichtigsten Phase wo wo
man dann ein Sohn oder eine Tochter
hoffentlich gesund nämlich eben hat
zuzusehen wie man eigentlich wiederkommt
und dann auf einmal schon läuft und ich
weiß gar nichts davon weil man nur
unterwegs ist und das muss so ein
bisschen passen man findet nie den
richtigen Zeitpunkt aber im Moment wäre
es noch ein Tick zu früh g dann bin ich
mal gespannt danke sehr sehr schön danke
vielen Dank super danke
schön